Today, I will talk about things related to wine
First thing, I would like to introduce myself, and what my company does
I've written down a couple of things here
We run wine shops
and we deal with restaurants and hotels, whole sale, with department stores
Around Japan, including Tokyo, we transact with about 2,000 stores
We also have restaurants in Asakusabashi and Kiyozumishirakawa
In Osaka, we have about 8 restaurants and wine shops
What makes us different from others is that
we grow in our own vineyard which is about 2.5 hectares wide
Including the grapes we grow and the grapes we buy from other farmers
We produce about 60,000 bottles of wine a year
When you say 60,000 bottles, it sounds like a lot
but one bottle is sold for 2,000 yen
So, when you do the math, the numbers aren't that big
We also import wine and beer
Also, wine school, this is where we met with Shinobu-san at the academy Du Vin
We also run the Tsuji Culinary Institute
We also do lectures and talks such as this
We also do written work for the Japan Sommelier Association Quarterly journal and the culinary press
What's unique with us is that no other company has all of these things included
Companies are usually divided into different sets of companies
Most of them do specialized work for each field
In our case, we specialize, but from producing wine and consuming it
we manage all of it. Just think of us as an odd company that does all these things
Today, what we would like you take home is this
I actually always jump to different places in the country to see contract farmers and purchasing
And to be honest I think every place I go to except for Tokyo is in the province
Osaka, you may think that it's bigger in size
but what I realized after spending most of my time in Osaka
Osaka is just another province
I really think so
From Osaka city, by car about 40 minutes
By train that would be 30 to 40 minutes in this kind of scenery
There are many that find this surprising, but at the beginning of the Showa era
there was a time that it was number one, surpassing Yamanashi in the most produced grapes
During the time that it had the most wineries
How many do you think there were Shinobu-san?
When Osaka had the most wineries in the Showa era, how many do you think there were?
How many wineries do you think there were?
About 10?
At its peak there were 119 wineries
According to the taxation office, there were 119 fruit wine brewing licenses
Santory which has become a household name, used to be called Kotobukiya
My friend's family used to run a successful winery, and started with beer, then they failed
And they sold this to Kotobukiya
Suntory also has their main office in Osaka
but the winery in Osaka was originally the main one
Then they started to get into beer, and from there they would get into whiskey
Now they are 3rd in production quantity of Delaware grapes, which is the 7th most produced grapes
There is still a 450 hectares of vineyard
and 90% of these are Delaware
In terms of generation, around up to my generation
Delaware is usually associated with the summer
It was often put in a box and on top of the table in the summer
The grapes that particularly reminded of summer was Delaware grapes
So, where is this made?
This is Osaka prefecture, and Nara is here, then there is Kyoto
Around the the boundary with Nara, number 5, 6, and 7 are within this Kawachi region
You may have heard of Kawachi wine
but it's actually now a name of a winery
It used to refer to the wine produced in this Kawachi region
and this grape was often made at number 6 and 7
Nakakawachi region, Minamikawachi region, Yao city, Kashiwara city, Habikino, Taishi are the main vineyards
Please take a look at this map
This is within Osaka city
Here, Kashiwara city is very close, then there is Habikino, and Taishi
Thanks to the highway
our winery is actually in the city and it's close to the Matsuyamachi station
For example, around this area
if Nanba was Roppongi, then maybe 1 or 2 stations away would be Matsuyamachi station
Around this area, the grapes are transported from here to here
It's quite close
In a 30 to 40 minute drive you will see this kind of scenery
A scenery covered in vineyards, it still exists
I'd like everyone to keep in mind that many grapes and wine are still locally produced
Our main work happens in the 2.5 hectare vineyard in Kajiwara city inside the Nakakawachi region of Osaka
What we are known to be unique for is
that we do not have our winery close to the vineyard
It’s been 11 years since I started the company
I came from a typical family, and it’s been almost 12 years since I started my business
Since I came from not having much money, I started a business where I wouldn't need to spend much
This’s the philosophy that I had
I wanted to make wine for a long time, even going abroad to train, and I started as a wine shop
From there I headed to creating a winery
Originally, I asked the 103 year old Katashimo winery by outsourcing the cultivating and brewing
We borrowed and used their place and their facilities
And from there, we moved on to our own winery
This
When you look at it, it looks like any other forest
This is what is called an abandoned farmland
Japan used to be the top producer of grapes
Flatlands have all turned residential, and since there are other ways of livelihood, there is no one to inherit them
When you are commuting for 30 to 40 minutes, you can make it to Osaka city
Since there aren't any manual laborers
These areas were originally vineyards, and there are framings called trellis training
On top of this, after a year or two, it goes back to being a forest, which we call abandoned farmland
Once you go inside
there is a grape tree, and wires, and scraps
This place has different things growing from it called an abandoned farmland
Abandoned farmlands are a big concern in agriculture in Japan
Not only in Osaka, but from Hokkaido to Okinawa, there are more and more that have such concerns
Why is this?
It’s because there is no one else to do it
Why is it that there is no one else to do it?
To be honest, it’s because it's not profitable
For young people, it's very important if they can survive from it or not
Most of the people who are in agriculture, except for our team
Are seniors, that are around 24 years older than us, and most of them are in their 60s
Most of them are pensioners
The farmers around us are mostly pensioners, and top of that, they would have income from the grapes
They are somewhat being able to enjoy their life
But if a younger generation were to do it, the current state of the industry is that it does not pay well
In this kind of vineyard, we would spend about a month, and work on it like this
For myself, I studied a bachelor of arts degree, and I had a typical middle class family
I didn't have the experience in agriculture, and I had not studied chemistry either which was needed for brewing
It was mostly self-taught, and that was my background before jumping into the winery
We also spent about 1 month in this, and mostly on my own, and in this state
After 2 months, we would make a terraced field, and we would plant trees
This would take up to about 3 months
We mostly only use our hands in working to recover the vineyards from being abandoned farmlands
This is what it looks like
I am a complete stranger in this area
And even when I asked around to lend us farmlands
The reality was that we would only receive lands like this that were tough to work on
Actually, at the back of this land there was land that had a very beautiful grape tree planted on it
We had asked to rent it out
After planting a grape tree, it takes about 4 to 5 years to bear fruits
When you make it to wine, it takes about 1 to 2 years to brew
It actually has a very bad cashflow that will only start making money after 6 years since you start working on it
I think it's number one in the list of jobs you shouldn't take
This and whiskey, I personally don't think you should touch those 2
It really takes 4 to 5 years for it to bear grapes after planting it
At the back of this, there is a tree planted that will start bearing this year
We asked to rent that land but one of the problems with Japanese agriculture is that they don't lend to strangers
Even if there was someone that wanted to rent, they will not lend it to strangers
I think that has resulted to many things
During this time, about 5 years ago
I was very passionate, not that I am not now
But during this time, I was young and very passionate
I would visit the landowner every day
And I would tell them that I would work hard to make very good wine from it
I would pay for it, so please lend it to me
I had done this every day
And after going in every single day, I thought that that would solve the problem
I thought that my feelings and passion would translate
But the landowner had grown annoyed of me, and they had cut all the trees
That was it
That is the first time I realized that there are times that you cannot translate passion
Ultimately, what I learned from this incident was
As long as I don't gain trust in this area, nothing would move forward
One of the reasons we rented this land was
That it has the closest farm seen from the town
The reason why we chose to rent this is
When we look out we can see the town
And from the town they can see the mountain
From seeing a mountain filled with farms that had rotted away
From this, when it becomes like this
The scenery seen from the town also changes
When the scenery from the town changes, people start to gossip and ask who is working on that land
And you continue to do this, and continue to improve the farm
People will start to know that we will not runaway from the responsibilities, and their perception changes
By changing the scenery from the town, the people from this area start to think that "there are strange ones that has come"
But they can see that we are working very hard on the vineyard
And as a result, from around the 3rd year
We started to receive inquiries from farmers if we were interested in renting out their vineyard
The name abandoned farm has a very negative connotation
But it sounds as if it's a heavy baggage
But for myself, I consider it as oil
I see it the same way as oil
And when it's processed properly, and made well
Just like fuel oil, gasoline, or gas
It's a type of resource
What we are working on now is
It isn't simply agricultural
But we are utilizing farm land that have been abandoned
Our project is to creating something new
The main result of one of the projects is wine
There are times that the moment we restore the land and snow comes
For some reason, when it snowed very hard in Osaka that was out of season, the farm was gone in one night
Many things happen, and there are also land that are at steep areas like this
Because we would get land that no one wanted to work on
There are land that doesn't have any streets around them
Places where cars can't get by
These are the types of abandoned farms that we would get
There was a time when we were doing it between houses
The land owner sold it in the midst of it, so now there are places where there isn't a vineyard anymore
There are many troubles or happenings that occurred
Despite them, we just kept continuing
We worked hard to turn them to wine, and actually turn it into a business
At the beginning, we started with 0.1 hectare for our wine
In 5 years, we now have 2 hectares, and have grown 20 times in size
There isn't anyone else to do it, so most abandoned lands would come to us
There aren't young people
A lot of different farmers would ask us to do theirs
In 5 years, 2 hectares
During this time, we had still been asking the old winery to lend us a space in their winery to make the wine
At a corner
After a year we were making 1 thousand bottles, and then 3 thousand the following year
On the 3rd year, we have about 5 thousand and at this point
The winery had told us that it wasn't a small corner anymore
The next year, we estimated that it would go over 5 thousand
So, they told us to move out, they didn't tell us this in a straight-forward way but
But they had this aura
Then, we decided to make our own winery
We looked for locations that would be good for our winery
Assuming that it would be bringing in a big amount of grapes
We wanted to turn these grapes to our own wine
So, we had made this decision
In the map I showed earlier, it takes about 30 to 40 minutes by train to get to Osaka city
It's about the distance until Yokohama
Actually, Kajiwara which is right next to the vineyard is a bedroom town
The prices of land are very high, and it's not a provincial rate, but the rate of a normal residential quarter
We looked for land that was close to the vineyard
After 3 months, we still couldn't find a place
No matter how much we looked, we were starting to wonder why
Then, I read an article in a magazine
That talked about a juice factory inside an apartment in New York
So that's it
This juice factory had the same kind of press machine that we needed
For a moment, the idea came to us that we could do it inside the city too
We thought about the reason the vineyard had to be close to the winery in the first place
The moment the vineyard and winery connect, is only during harvest
The only thing needed is to transport the grapes during harvest
If it takes about 1 hour, this is a typical distance even in Europe
From the vineyard, we drew a one hour radius, and within it fell Osaka city
Before we talked about Osaka city
The type of winery I wanted to do was something that worked along a restaurant
The reason is that when I visited Australia for a working holiday
There was a great winery and restaurant
It left a lasting impression on me
This was in the province
And I thought to myself that I wanted to do something like it
But then Kajiwara was an expensive bedroom town, and also considering other things
When we mixed all our other ideas, we came up with Osaka city
We moved the idea from the suburbs to the city, towards renting property
When we came up with the idea of doing it in an apartment
There were issues regarding building a winery
But eventually, all came to place
For a small winery, it takes about 30 million yen to make
And half of that is usually the land costs and building costs
But since we have a rental winery
Those fees cost close to nothing
But, of course it will become costs later on, but it doesn't cost as much
First thing is, as the issue in creating a winery was the equipment, there are points about money written here
First thing is that there are only about 250 wineries in Japan
It's very few
250 means that the industries around it aren't as developed
I wouldn't say that the companies are ripping us off, but they are making a profit
Compared to Europe, the equipment are more expensive
I wanted to make wine that was easy to drink and that was cheap
These are the types of wine that you have in front of you
In other words, drinking refreshing wine within the year
That is our stance
We weren't able to buy the heavy equipment
We weren't able to buy it, you will see it later on
There is a huge press machine
Normally, people would bring it in from Europe
When you import this, one equipment would cost about 8 million to 9 million Yen
Then we thought, if the Italians can make it, maybe the Japanese can also make it
I went to the local metal factory in Osaka, and I asked them to make the same kind
Then, it only cost 2.5 million Yen
The delivery time was also one-third of the time, and they would come and fix issues with a call in 15 minutes
We also had other equipment made there
In actual, when you just look at the winery, it had cost us less than 10 million Yen
We were able to start
During this time, there weren't a lot of people that were doing it
Even up to now there weren't as many
There are only up to 250
And 250 isn't a big number for breweries
There aren't many people who have done it
There aren't many information, not like information for restaurants
The control is with the tax office
From not being able to tell what is okay and what isn't
It was very hard
As I have said earlier, as it takes money and time
For small companies like us, it was very heavy
The approval of the the tax office was very hard
At that time, rental wineries did not exist
So, when I was learning law in college, I remember my professor teaching me
Things that aren't said you cannot do, are things that you can do
If you search what school I went to earlier then I might get in trouble
I remembered about this
They didn't say that it was not allowed, so we thought that renting was okay
When we applied at the tax office
They had turned us away
At first, we brought all the requirements
The documents were perfect, but they wouldn't approve it, and they had turned us down about an odd reason
Later on, they had been very cooperative in helping us
This is the kind of problems we had, but eventually, we were able to move to Matsuyamachi station that was 1 minute away
To start our winery
This is during the event, and you can see the tank
It's usually inside
The first floor is the winery, and the second floor is the restaurant
By making the 2nd floor a restaurant, the rental for this is paid for the 2nd floor
It might sound like the restaurant is ripping off the customers
But we do set the price very reasonably
We always made sure to rent at very cheap
What we are often asked about it that if the condition of the grapes are still good if it's a winery in the city
They ask if it doesn't go bad quickly
As we mentioned earlier, we also run a wine shop, and deliver ourselves
From the vineyard to the winery, we can delivery in about ???
Compared to wineries around, it can be delivered in a very good state and condition
It's only 50 meters away on the big road called the Nagahori street
I am washing the tank here, and at the back, there are many cars passing by, this is where we make wine
This winery was born in 2013
When you try to search our name in the media
You will find many stories about it being the first urban winery
But it wasn't that we were targeting to have this kind of title
We weren't able to buy land or building for the winery close to the vineyard
But the truth is that we weren't able to do it close the vineyard, so we had no choice to make it an urban winery
This is the press machine I was telling you earlier
This is Japan made
Many of these are Japan made, for example this tank is also Japan made, or Osaka made rather
They are all hand made, and most of the harvested grapes are sent to the winery in refrigerated vehicles
Each grape is picked by hand
And the winery in Japan often performs chaptalization
They often add sugar, or adjust the sour taste
We do not do much, actually we do not do any of these
Especially this acid can add to the sourness
We have never performed chaptilization
There are also oxidation inhibitors
The wine we have can be muddy
This is because we don't filter it
There is also the preservatives, that is called oxidation inhibitors
If less than half of the winery is used
The oxidation inhibitor is what holds it longer
Our wine is something that you should finish in a year
So, it doesn't matter
By doing so, it gives a refreshing taste to the wine, as you might have noticed
It's this kind of step
There is a press machine that is hand made
That means that is only 30 tsubo worth of area
Here, we make about 30,000 bottles for Osaka
Our own wine that was made with our own hands
The restaurant in the 2nd floor uses ingredients taken from neighboring areas
Especially in Osaka, the best ??? In Osaka???
Osaka also shows up here
This kind of farm is also in the neighborhood
There are these kinds of cattle ranch and pig farm
We also provide Italian cuisine with ingredients from around the area
It says that it's a "The way of drinking at a wine region"
As you see on the picture there is a beer keg here
Let me share the reason why I decided to make cheap but good tasting wine
It's when I was at my reunion
When all of my classmates got together and had drinks
I think you might have wine after beer
But no one wanted to order wine
It was because it was expensive
For salarymen these days
When they are married, they are usually on allowance
Is there anyone here on allowance?
May there aren't any from Google
I came from a normal school, and I had friends that were on a 30,000 Yen per month allowance
When you consider this, wine is too expensive to drink
They won't be able to drink a bottle that costs 3,000 to 4,000 Yen
Or even 700 or 800 Yen per glass is too expensive
It was sad that I couldn't drink wine when I was drinking with my classmates
There weren't good wine that was affordable, the cheap ones tasted the price
I considered many things
As our company also goes by the concept of the "Everyday Wine"
To make it an everyday wine
If we didn't fix the price, it would only simply be lip service
In the current Japanese market
There actually weren't many local wine that had tasted well
Our main work was a wine shop
As we were marketing these wine, we were able to identify what was lacking in the market
And it started from when I had seen my classmates
When we thought of what was the daily alcoholic beverage
In Japan, this is typically beer
So, what is the price range of beer
The price of beer at restaurants, even if it was expensive, it would still be around 500 Yen
I think a glass of draft beer is around 500 Yen
So, if you could drink good wine for 500 Yen a glass
We thought that people would drink it
We made the computation to make good wine from local grapes that only costs 500 Yen per glass
No matter how we computed it, making it 500 Yen was impossible
We thought about it for a long time, and we wrote down all the costs
The bottle, labels, caps, seals, and even cardboard boxes
When we listed them down, the price would go up when we put any of those in
For the initial cost of the grapes, for example 1 bottle of wine uses around 1 kilogram of grapes
750ml to a kilogram of grapes is used
This 1 kilogram, and the price of the content of the wine and the materials outside of it were about the same costs
This means that when you buy a bottle of wine, you are spending half of it on waste
Even with other drinks, the reality is that the content does not cost as much
The costs are mostly on the container and the transportation
In the case of wine, it's the same, for the 250 Yen Delaware
The materials including the bottle, the label, and all are about 250 Yen
As long as we don't cut all of these, a 500 Yen glass cannot be served
So, what we came up with was
Because we only transport from the winery at the 1st floor to the restaurant upstairs, we cut everything
We made a beer keg that we could use semi-permanently
And when this became empty, we would bring it downstairs
We would put this kind of nozzle on it, and put it directly on the glass
We created wine that didn't produce any waste
We call it the draft barrel wine
This is actually pushed out by carbon dioxide, so it does not use electricity, for the one we offer in Osaka
This is also home made
These are the things we can do because we are a winery, and isn't very suitable for oxidant inhibitors or delivery
But if it just sending from the 1st to the 2nd floor, it's the perfect refreshing wine
This restaurant serves wine that can be consumed because it's a wine region, and because it's a winery
This is how we see the role of a winery
With farm produced in Japan, it works the same as a restaurant in that, the only way to make a sale is through seats multiplied by through customer transaction
The same way with farms, the sale is made by "the crops taken from the farm" multiplied by "the unit price", that's why they do not have much profit
By adding value to this, by adding value to the agriculture will allow it to continue to work
Talking about prices may not be the best way, but a kilogram of grapes is 250 Yen
The moment it turns to wine, it becomes 2,500 Yen
This is how you can add value to it
If agriculture becomes something that makes profit, we think that the younger generation will start to come back to it
By doing this, if we increase the number of followers, agriculture will continue to prosper
Another is suggesting different ways of drinking wine
Wine usually has the image that there are only certain types of people that drink it
But in actual, there aren't much rules to it
For example, the Delaware wine that you have been trying as a type of grape for wine
In Europe, it's not accepted as a grape for wine
For example, if we put a label on it and said it was Delaware
We wouldn't be able to export it
It's because in Europe, it would not be considered as wine
But it's wine
There is this strong stereotype among Japanese about the world of wine
Eliminating these prior ideas, and by putting importance in the current
Wine and alcoholic drinks can be very enjoyable
It can be used as a communication tool
We want to spread this more
In most cases, it ends here
It usually ends here, but a new problem has arisen
The increase in abandoned farmlands in Osaka isn't stopping
This year, many farms have contacted us requesting for their land to be rented out
Our weakness as a leasing winery is that we cannot expand
If you had land you can increase the number of facilities
Because we cannot increase in number of production quantity, when the farms increase, it has to stop at some points
Also, our own grapes are all for white wine
For example, we buy black grapes from other areas
For example, we also purchase grapes from Yamanashi, Nagano, and Yamagata prefecture
But the transportation takes very long
It's too much to bring grapes taken from the East and bringing it to the West
And the abandoned farmlands in Osaka keep increasing
After 5 years time, our winery will be too full with our own grapes
It wouldn't be able to accommodate any more
If Yamagata, Nagano, Yamanashi has the same issue as Osaka
If there were issues in abandoned farmlands
And if we stop buying these grapes, the contract farmers that we bought from
What will they do when we stop buying from them
When you look at Japan as a whole
Just because we saved the abandoned farmlands in Osaka
This may cause to create abandonment in other areas
We finally realized that it would be meaningless
We had to overcome the transportation costs and time issues
As a result
There was only the option of expanding or creating another winery
As a solution, we decided to create a new branch
Then, we thought about where we were gonna have it
Our contract farmers at that time were scattered in Yamanashi, Yamagata, and Nagano
What is most interesting is, the most efficient place to collect grapes from all these 3 places was
When we take out the common denominator for these, the most efficient location was Tokyo
This is because the transportation network is spread within the city in the middle of it all
For example, we have a contract farmer in Ibaraki and Chiba prefecture
When I try to go from the contract farmer in Chiba to the one in Ibaraki
Normally, you would just go to the upper right, or to North East
When you use your car navigation, it will use the highway, and go back to Tokyo first
It goes back to Tokyo first, and go out of it again
In Yamanashi and Yamagata, it's the same way
So we realized that the place that you can collect grapes the fastest is Tokyo
We thought that we could take the urban winery plus restaurant model to Tokyo
From this idea, the Kiyosumishirakawa Fujimaru brewery was born
It's in Koto ward, and as long as you don't get the exit wrong it's 5 to 6 minutes away from Kiyosumishirakawa station
It's just a typical looking house
The landlord lives in the 3rd floor, this is also a leased winery
1st floor is the winery, 2nd floor is the restaurant, and the 1st floor looks like this
Within the area, there is an apartment
And a residential house on this side
It's really right in the middle of the residential area in Koto ward right at the back alley
We created a winery in the middle
We decided to bring in the grapes taken from our contract farmers we had been buying from
We decided it do it in a way that doesn't cut the income of farmers and without decreasing the production quantity
The 1st floor looks like this, and it was originally a steel factory
We remodelled the existing steel factory like this, and you can see someone peek here
She's sitting right there, and she is the wine maker
We use good equipment here
In the Kiyosumishirakawa branch, the headquarters of the company that handles equipment is close by
They said that they can come right away if we needed help, the same equipment from Osaka isn't used, and imported equipment is mostly used
We created here a winery that was exclusively for purchased grapes
At the 2nd floor, there is a tasting room like this
In this restaurant, colorful dishes such as this are served
Currently, the chef is Italian, and he creates unique dishes
Let's talk about the things that we do here
After starting an urban winery, we thought what our next step was
In Japan today, we have declining birth rates and avoidance of alcohol issues
These are recent concerns in the alcohol industry
I think that many here do not smoke anymore
When I was young, a lot of people were smoking
Our fathers and mothers
But after 10 to 20 years
Cigarettes have turned into the evil
There are many who want it to disappear from this world
As alcohol and cigarettes being the same kind of indulgence
What we most fear of is
To be the evil in society
There really are cases where they are obliterated from the world
With this said, we have to find a way to be an existence that is needed in society
As an industry, we have to be much bigger
This generation isn't about drinking a lot
But, having 1 glass a day is just fine
This is the kind of activities that we are trying to do
Do you know the consumption of wine in Japan is?
I only know Shinobu-san's name so
How much do you think it's?
Japan as a whole
How many bottles of wine do you think we consume?
In a year
Adults that are of legal age, how many bottles a year do you think?
About 2 bottles? In a year?
Good guess
In average it's about 4 bottles
4 bottles is in a year
Don't we drink that amount in a week?
That is the numbers
That means, that the gap between those who drink and those who don't is very wide
Of course, there are those that are financially restricted even if they wanted to
That is why I think it has become a drink that only a few people enjoy
I would like to reach out to those that do not drink now
What we came up with is to put children into the mix
They will be our customers and 10 to 20 years time
We want to show that wineries can be fun, and it's about craftsmanship
We want them to understand that it isn't anywhere scary, or harmful, but it's something that is fun and enjoyable
We thought that they could be on our side in the future
We also have hand squeezing experiences that we offer with parents
They are taught to take out the stems, and squeeze it through the press machine
The juice comes out, and goes into the fermentation tank
After this, they go to the 2nd floor to have a meal, and we charge around 500 to 1000 Yen for this, so it's in the red
In the restaurant, they would use knives and forks together and eat with their kids
They can also drink the juice, and after finishing the fermentation
They can be packed in the bottle, and a label is put on it
While the children can put anything they want on it, and they paste in the bottle as a memorabilia for the parents and kids
When we do this, you cannot drink it that easily, right
But the parents want to drink, so they usually buy another bottle
When they come to buy, that is when it makes a profit
This is the kind of activities and events we have
By doing so, we want to increase our fans for the future
And convey the beauty of wine to the younger generations like yourself, and this is something we do regularly
The other day, this is something I talked about a lot at a university
Craftsmanship from now on isn't simply processing
The time where selling is the most important thing is over
What the government is working on now is the 6 sectors of economy
We typically have the primary for the farmers and fishery
And manufacturing in the second, and the tertiary section as the services
When you add up 1, 2, and 3 together, you have 6, and this is where the new movement comes from
It boils down to asking someone to make something who doesn't know what sells
The end product will not match the needs of society
What we are doing is, people from the tertiary section doing primary and secondary work
It's marketing mixed with secondary and primary
We understood what was lacking in society, and we found the wine that was lacking
This way of thinking has brought us much attention that has obviously increased our opportunities to speak about it
What we always think is that
We believe in the power of wine
The reason why we can receive this kind of opportunity is because of the power of wine
A glass can strike up a conversation
Even if the wine tasted good or bad, it's a drink that brings out conversations
Even if you like it or not, it's a type of drink that will bring out some kind of word
And finally
In the wine that you are drinking now has Osaka and Yamagata Delaware in them
It's also a good way to draw interest in these local areas
By making it into wine, it can instantly connect the land and and the consumer
I think this is the kind of work it does
From the national classification, a winery is a food processing factory
When it's a food processing factory
It falls in the same as packing canned goods, and bottling drinks
But we always direct our attention to agriculture, when we work
Winery usually uses a large amount of grapes
We use, 60 tons of grapes
60 tons of grapes influences a large space of farm
When there is one winery, only that amount of grapes is needed, and that amount of farm will be kept
As long as we work hard in delivering to the customers
00:45:54,100 --> 00:45:01,000
We can start to see the new shape of agriculture
It can be the interaction between customers and drinkers
It can be the interaction between the drinker and the creator
It can provide different situations
From a simple food processing factory
When it changes to a winery
In this time we are in, it's not simply about making something
A little extra something must be added, if not, I think there isn't a way to survive
It was a long talk, but these are the efforts we are working on
Thank you